i'm going to talk today about
something
i've been thinking about for a long time
you know i was trained at the university
of alberta by rick sutton who
you know if you've read the rl textbook
is
you know is a master and pure assistant
and really cares about um doing
experiments well and so that's been
passed on to me and i passed on my
students and i'd like to pass that on to
you guys today
um see i'm from the university alberta
and i'm from deepmind
and uh let's get into it let's have some
fun
i've kind of made this um
so that there's different points i can
stop based on your questions and
interactions so if
we start discussing things and there's
lots of questions don't worry about it
that that's built into the plan
but i did want to start with my key
messages because i want to give them
upfront because i think
you can understand them before i even
get into it and then i'll show them
again at the end so like the first
simple key message and i say it when i'm
an area chair reviewer i say to my
students it's like
you need more runs than you than you
think you do you need more seeds
um the other big one is just the
emphasis to take a statistical point of
view what you're doing like think about
the distributions underlying the
performance that you're trying to
measure
how you're trying to characterize that
distribution performance and what
statistical assumptions you're making
when you're doing things like confidence
intervals and the different things you
might report it's very important to
think about those things carefully
hyper parameters are really important
i'm going to get into this in detail but
basically we need to think about the
hyper parameters of your method and the
methods you're comparing against and
sweeping is not an algorithmic answer
for deployment
obviously you want to watch it for on
tuned bass lines if your bass lines are
untuned it means you might be misleading
with your results
and then the last and probably the most
important actually is
you know this appeal to authority
fallacy i've seen this all over the
place i've seen research senior
researchers tell to me which is
basically i see bad empirical practice
in papers so therefore it's okay to copy
it and that's not the case of course we
can be better
and so i just want to remind us that you
know we're scientists right like we're
computer scientists it's it's in the
name and so science typically is the
study of the natural world
but computing science is a little bit
different i don't call computer science
it's not the it's not the science of
computers like those objects it's the
science of computing
so that's what we study not the natural
world but that also means that we pose
questions and seek answers by typically
inventing problems it's not like
we're going to understand this thing in
biology or you know what dinosaurs did
we make up the problems we study
so we've got the problem setting
we invent the mvp the environment the
agent and the experiment protocol all of
this is under our control under our
invention
and that creates a dynamical system
right it's not a data set and a learning
algorithm it's a program interacting
with another program and we want to
study that
but at the end of the day you know
empiricists like me and you guys today
and theorists and algorithm designers
we're all trying to do the same thing we
want knowledge which is insights and
understanding that's the goal of science
that's the goal of writing a paper and
that's what we're all about
so i wanted to just get you to think
about an area of science that i think
about all the time because first i think
these guys are you know the best and
purest in the world
and i think this is where you know the
future of ai is going anyway we're going
to be analyzing these systems almost
like they're animals
so just think about you know this
picture this rabbit it's in a it's an
apparatus to hold it still so we can do
eye blink experiments on it
you don't need to know the details of
how these experiment works but basically
we're trying to understand
how
how the animal comes to predict stimuli
based on these eye blink events
and so every day the researcher is going
to run several rabbits through this
apparatus
and this this experiment is going to
take days and days and days to run bring
the rabbit over the apparatus run your
experiment go get a new rabbit
etc etc
and the researchers are very very
careful when you read about what they do
they're very careful about controlling
the lighting how they handle animals
um they don't want to wear strong scents
that they don't want to pet the animals
in any particular way then they want to
control the environment conditions and
obviously they can't do this perfectly
but they're thinking about it all the
time because they're good empiricists
and this is the kind of level of
inspection and care that we should be
taking in our experiments because
in many many ways it's way way easier
for us
okay
so think about what we get to do as
empirical rl researchers we get to
construct the environment and
that the agent operates in and perfectly
control that experiment protocol you
know like when when the agent starts
where the agent starts when decisions
are made when the experiment ends
all of that is under our control
we can isolate the sources of variation
think about the poor animal learning
scientists that there's genetic factors
that some rabbits are are dumb and never
learned that some rabbits are really
sharp some rabbits are heavier than
others they can't control those nor can
they often observe but we can in our
individual ages we know how to
initialize our agents and what it means
um and we can perfectly instrument our
experiments we can collect huge amounts
of data all through our agent all
through the environment
detecting little tiny things in the
learning system
and and you know what's happening
between the learning system and the
environment
and of course you know animal learning
people can run a couple rabbits in
parallel but that's limited by the
number of people that can run those
experiments we are not we get to run
independent trials in parallel on large
clusters
so we have it really easy in that sense
and we get to do this all in computers
right so it's way way faster in real
time you can't do animal learning any
faster than real time but we can and we
can start up new experiments in minutes
where you know new experiments animal
learning you only get to do it once you
better hope your date is good so they're
going to be very very careful on how
they set up their spread
and yet
you know poor empirical practice is
common in reinforcing learning and this
this is not just me being a grumpy old
researcher i just i come across it all
the time
in highly cited papers
in in
conference reviewing everywhere and
you know this is an age-old problem in
computer science and machine learning
and let's talk about just
you know the history of this trend
so you know i'm talking about this
mounting evidence of poor scholarship
but of course this goes
way further back there's a quote in this
paper so this is the troubling trends
machine learning scholarship paper from
2018
and you know one of the quotes in that
paper was a quote from someone in the
70s
saying the scholarship in in ai research
is poor and we're making claims that
aren't supported by our evidence they
were worried about it back then we've
been worried about it all along
this this is just kind of a constant
battle and my goal here today is to
train you to be the next generation of
empiricists that do better and fight
this trend
and so you know the classic things we
see in and this was this was generally
just about machine learning not about
about reinforced learning was
failure to distinguish speculation and
explanation you know we always get
excited about results and say oh well
maybe this means that our agents can
reason and they they have consciousness
that's not an explanation that's just
wild speculation and if you're going to
do it you should definitely label the
speculation but what we really care
about is the second part the explanation
the understanding of the phenomenon
failure to identify sources
of improvement in our experiments this
is a really key one our job isn't just
to show that something's the best it's
to understand what's working and why
you know this is a classic one in
in machine learning papers using math to
impress and confuse the reader that's
that's just not good and using language
poorly right
using
fancy words or trying to inject meaning
that you don't have support for so you
know i made up an example here
some agent is curious about the world
we're trying to make the reader think
that the agent is more capable than it
is by using this word curious even
though it's totally non-technical and
not necessarily supported by our data in
any general sense
so you know that was wider machine
learning but of course this has been
happening in in in rl and in dprl and so
you know joel pino's lab led by
henderson looked into this
and there's a couple papers on this and
it's had a really big impact right and
the first thing they did was they just
highlighted
conflicting results you see in the
lecture like
you you look at this algorithm on this
domain and then you look at another
domain and it's worse and we're not
seeing consistency across domains or
across papers or even across
replications of experiments
so that paper really was pushing this
this focus on reproducibility and of
course that that has been gaining steam
in the community
and they also advocated for doing more
runs like i said
um and yeah they they did a really nice
set of experiments but they showed
things like network architectures
activation functions and all kinds of
other hyper parameters including the
code base matters a lot for the
performance you get and that's kind of a
situation that we don't want to be in
because then when you go behind that
work
trying to recreate it trying to build on
it becomes very very difficult
and so this is kind of a case study just
to show you an example of what we found
so this was work done by my student sam
and you know our intent was not to
you know show something was broken this
was actually something sam was doing for
another project because he's interested
in policy grading algorithms
and so he wanted to compare to relevant
methods from the literature so he wanted
to reproduce some results from the
lecture
and so this was just a well-known result
i'm not going to talk about the names of
the albums because i don't think that's
important here i just want to use this
as a vehicle to kind of highlight some
empirical trends
and so you know this is the learning
curve and i'm going to show a lot of
learning curves in this in this talk
so what i really want you to do is
understand you know the x-axis of this
curve is basically interaction with the
world
and the y-axis is performance and for
all my plots i believe the y-axis high
is good so basically what we want is as
you get more and more interaction with
the world as you go right on this graph
the performance goes up and up and up
and up right so you see these kind of
like exponential learning curves that
ramp up quickly and then stabilize right
so that's that's what a learning curve
means i'm gonna refer to it a lot
um
so in this case we ran this experiment
and you know maybe this doesn't look
surprising right away this looks like
not a great result to me but we'll get
into that
but the things i wanted to highlight
here was
you know this number 5000 was lower than
reported in the in the paper that we
were trying to replicate like quite a
bit lower um
the size of these these error ribbons
were much much larger than we reported
and we actually have two lines here for
the baseline we're comparing against
because it was totally unclear from us
reading the paper and then looking at
the repository which which baseline was
actually used which this is supposed to
be the same algorithm purple and blue
are the same algorithm but they're
different implementations and we
couldn't tell which one they used
and so what did we find in this case
study
well we found that the repository
contained
wrappers for two different code bases
and that's why we couldn't tell which
baseline they used because there was two
different ways they could have ran the
baseline algorithm and it wasn't
clarified at all
the paper
neither the paper nor the repository
specify the hyper parameters for the
baseline method so we were left to tune
those by ourselves which is very very
difficult these are large complicated
learning systems and these experiments
are very expensive
and the repository can include all kinds
of algorithm components that weren't
mentioned in the paper at all
and so at the end of the day we just
couldn't reproduce the result that's
what i showed you in the previous slide
we did 30 runs even though the original
work did five so we wanted to get a
stronger sense of what was going on we
did extensive hyper primer sweeping and
ablation the architecture and the
implementation details and we just
couldn't get it
so then i we kind of had the idea to do
like the mythbusters approach and i
don't know if you see mythbusters but
you know there's a myth out there
they check the myth it turns out false
and then their next step is well what
will we have to do to make the myth true
right and so that this is what we did
and so part of that is just even more
hyperparameter tuning
but another one was looking at the
individual runs of the system the
individual learning curves that makes up
this average and we noticed that some
runs were very good
and somewhat runs were very bad
and we also noticed that the repo
contained code to search for good hyper
parameters
or for good seats and so
we thought maybe what happened was that
they ran the experiment once and they
got some results and then they made some
changes which maybe those changes
weren't important but then they ran it
again later and they got five good seats
and so when we did that when we looked
for five good seeds at a 30 we got
something that almost exactly reproduced
the
the result from the paper
and so what we see is much higher
performance in the mean of this orange
line and really tight um
shaded region
and uh
and then so we we decided that the third
thing we do so we did replication
um which we couldn't get and then we did
the mythbusters thing of how could we
make it look like the plot from the
paper and then we did the third thing
which is we tried to run a really good
experiment in our view
and so what we did is we did extensive
tuning of the baseline
we looked at how action selection noise
was injected and we we chose a different
method because that was known in the
literature be better
we also found that there was a possible
bug in how they treated the end of
episodes they treated as an environment
termination which is not correct
we don't know if that bug existed in
their baseline but we fixed that bug
in the code base
and then so we did 30 runs and instead
of
uh reporting
you know standard confidence intervals
with like you know a standard error we
use bootstrap confidence intervals and
this is what we think is a fair result
here and now we've noticed that
you know we can't clearly say that one
algorithm is better than the other and
in fact the purple one has come up quite
a bit due to extensive hyperparameter
tuning and so this is all kind of a
tease and uh and a suggestion for what
i'm i'm gonna get into today
but you know it's not just about this
talk um
there's lots of mounting work out there
about how to do this stuff well
there's a really nice paper about
basically it's a crash course in
statistics for irl i really love this
paper it's from inria the group at
indriya
um
a really nice paper from umass about how
to deal with hyper parameters well when
you're comparing algorithms because
that's a really hard problem
the insights we can get from small scale
experiments so this is from the google
brain team in montreal revisiting
rainbow and then there's been some nice
papers you know revisiting some
conclusions that were based on not great
experiments and debunking them by
running better experiments and better
analysis
so
you know there's troubling trends but
there's also a small army growing of
people who care and are trying to fight
the
this this trend
and so i just wanted to you know think
about what we want to be here because
you know you have to have a goal so as
an empiricist we might ask just a very
simple question
like how do we understand the
performance of a single learning
algorithm like q learning or sarsa i'm
not even going to compare it to other
things i just want to understand my
learning algorithm
and the implement chasing choices i've
made and as soon as you ask that simple
question then you have a bunch of
questions
or decisions to make right how long you
run the experiment
the number of of episode
do you count the number of episodes you
count the number of steps how you're
going to aggregate performance which
which environments you're going to use
there's tons and tons of questions
and different questions
lead to different design choices and so
there's going to be no standard recipe
today this is this is all just about
getting you to think about these choices
and how to make them well
so you know my first message to you was
you need more runs than you think so
this is just a simple experiment i ran
in the 10 arm bandit task from sutton
bartow
and so all i did here is i took a
well-tuned agent and you know the green
line is the mean performance average of
runs this is the typical learning curve
you expect to see
you know it starts slow and it comes up
and then it's
and then is is very nice and smooth
but that's because we averaged a bunch
of runs you know when we think about
these learning systems we should think
about deployment because that's
eventually where we might want to go or
we're not going to be averaging over
runs on a robot walking around your
house
or a agent controlling a water treatment
plant we're going to be getting one
right
and so even this nice smooth learning
curve when you look under the hood you
look at the best friend of the system
and the worst around the system
they're quite shaky they move up and
down a lot and they're very very
different
right and so how should we how should we
think about these things
so we should think about the
distribution performance like every time
you run this experiment you get another
run and so you get another piece of
insight about the
the distribution performance underlying
this interaction between the agent and
the environment
and so there's two key sources of
variation in in
in this this experiment you know the
stochasticity due to the agent
right when you initialize your agent you
pick random neural network weights and
during learning you might be using
epsilon greedy so the exploration
injects randomness
and of course often interesting
environments are stochastic either
random start states transition noise
all kinds of stuff
and so we want both of these things
actually for different reasons we want
our algorithms to be stochastic because
they work better that way like you know
if we initialize your neural network
with all zeros it's not going to learn
and then we want stochastic environments
because we want to check if our if our
agents are actually robust
so we want to vary the world to make
sure they're not just over fit to some
deterministic system
but this means that every trial is going
to be very very different and so you can
you can visualize these things right so
um this was compiled by andy patterson
and so
this is dqn running on card pull and
what we did is that we ran it we ran the
experiment many many many times and then
we switched that learning curve into a
scalar number and then we basically made
a histogram but we did it so many times
that we could do
kernel density estimation and get a
smooth thing
but basically this is showing that
you know the proportion of time that
you get just different amounts of
performance right and so what is this
showing here this is showing that how
often are you getting low performance
you know between zero and 100 compared
to really high performance like 300 and
this is card pulls so we're getting
we're getting positive reward for the
longer that we balance the whole so we
want to be higher in these numbers
but the first thing to notice is this is
not a normal distribution which is often
what we like to see in statistics it's a
bimodal distribution
and the mean of it is smack in the
middle of these two modes
which is awkward because we want our
mean to be represented that's the thing
we're reporting reporting the mean
learning curve and the mean here is
between these two modes
so
if we say
you know
that this is the mean then we're saying
that if you look at this distribution
then the agent is very likely to only
balance the poll for about 35 steps like
if you just had a new agent he would
likely balance the poll for 35 steps
less likely
but still possible that it would balance
the poll for about 250 steps but the
least likely thing to happen is it for
to balance it for 125 which is where the
mean is and so just computing the mean
from this distribution and thinking
about what all the runs of this system
um produced in terms of performance
distribution is an important thing to do
now i notice there's a q a thing
and there's lots of
long questions here
so those are going to be hard for me to
read as i go since they're so long so
maybe we're going to have to push them
to the end
and you know it's just important to keep
looking at
you know what this what the data of your
system looks like so this is an
experiment i ran with an n-step off
called ctd method on barrett's counter
example bears counter example is meant
to show the td diverges and so we expect
instability
but what you can see is a lot of the
runs of the system we're good you know
this is this is an error curve so
actually down is good
and so
and it's a log plot so that's why it has
this weird shape but basically you want
these kind of low sloping lines here
it's showing that the error is going
down and stabilizing but there's one run
of of 50 here that spiked way up and
came way back down
and so
you know it's it's really hard to just
look at averages of things and
understand this because now i know from
this learning system it has
one really bad run and if i'm thinking
about deploying this i should care about
this like this one way off the scale
and so my second message today is to
carefully consider how you aggregate
your data
and and what it what each choice means
right so we can characterize the
variability
in our distribution performance that
multimodal thing i showed you before one
simple thing is you report
the mean plus minus the variance right
and so this is nice because the variance
never goes to zero the more data you get
you're just variance estimate becomes
more accurate
but you know as we saw before this might
not be very reflective so we have dq
on acrobat there that's a nice normal
distribution that means the mean is
going to be very reflective of
what the performance will look like
but the cliff world example from the
textbook
that skewed way to one side and then we
have this nice video that andy made
which shows
you know as you go through the learning
curve how this performance distribution
is changing
and so it's not just that this
performance distribution might be
multimodal but it's actually different
every time
and so if we're thinking about what
distributional assumptions we're making
it also interacts with how long the
experiment was run for
and so
the only thing i'm trying to get across
to you here is these distributions are
complicated and we should think about
them and we always have access to them
because
those are the things i'm averaging to
produce my average learning curve
and so that means i had that data and i
could plot these distributions if i
wanted to it's not i'm not putting any
extra burden on the experimenter to look
at these
so another way you can you can aggregate
your data instead of
instead of looking at the mean and
variance which we know is a little bit
misleading we could use what's called
tolerance intervals and basically these
are percentiles of the age of
performance like
you know top temper
bottom 10 and top 90 with a fudge factor
based on the number of runs because
we won't we're going to be computing
those percentiles from data so we won't
have certainty in them
and so these are not to be confused with
constant rules and i'll show you what
they look like to kind of get that
across
you know this is this is dq in a
mountain car averaged over 200 runs
so i have the mean
plotted here the mean learning curve um
and the shaded region is corresponding
to a 95 confidence interval
is this a good summary of the variation
and performance of this agent that
underlying distribution
right because remember
composite rules are different thing and
i'll talk about that in the next slide
but let's look at some of the runs that
made up this knee
so you can see the blue line is just the
individual runs and some crash and come
back up
some are all over the place
you probably wouldn't have guessed that
that's what the runs look like based on
this mean curve
and so
you know the confidence interval was
quite tight
on that on that mean estimate because we
were quite certain that that's where the
mean was
but it doesn't reflect the underlying
performance variability and that's what
this comes these tolerance intervals on
the right show
and so we have some other algorithm the
red algorithm but basically if you
notice the tolerance interval for the
for dqn is the whole width of the graph
which means it's hard to say much
about about this performance
all right um
yeah and so the last one is you know
almost the i left the most common choice
to last because it's actually quite
technical um and there and there's lots
to talk about here and i'm not going to
get into it today but i will point you
to a document
that you can read more about it but
basically
confidence intervals are doing something
slightly different
we're trying to reflect our confidence
that the true performance is within some
range that's what it means
and that and so you can think about you
know applying the mean learning curve
with the standard error that's like a 66
confidence interval
um and and the nice thing there is if
you get enough data that confidence
range squishes down to zero which is not
true of those tolerance intervals or
even computing the variance
but there's often a lot of assumptions
attached to a confidence interval like
for instance a standard a standard
normal confidence interval or or even
just using the standard error
we assume that we know the variance that
that's how those things are constructed
and so we get data and so we estimate
that that variance from data
we also make distributional assumptions
oftentimes we make a normal distribution
assumption
and you know if you're so let's think of
the standard practice now three runs and
and just do standard error
on the bottom here i've just shown you
what these histograms of performance
look like for mountain car with
different numbers of runs so the first
one is three runs and then five runs and
then ten runs all the way up to a
thousand rounds
you know with low numbers of runs you're
just getting samples from this
distribution and they could be skewed up
or skewed down and they don't end up
looking anything like the slightly
skewed normal distribution that we
finish with
and so
you know this is
this is something that we really really
want to think about when we when we do
our data analysis
oops
okay so my advice is do more runs
i usually start with 10 runs and move up
from there people often say 30 but as
far as i can tell looking in the
literature there's no there's no basis
for the for the number 30.
um
and you know use better aggregation
techniques like you know just the
student t confidence interval
all of a sudden does a better job for us
because it has a multiplier
in front based on you know the number of
runs so
if we have a few runs then we're going
to have a bigger multiplier which means
we have a wider comps interval and
that's due to the uncertainty in the
variance estimate we could also do
bootstrap confidence intervals which
don't make distributional assumptions
which is really really nice and they're
this resampling procedure that basically
constructs an empirical distribution and
then you can get your statistics from
that
but that typically requires way more
runs than other choices and again i'm
going to point you to
a couple places to read way more about
this stuff
and so you know this is often a remark i
get from
especially you know in interacting with
authors who have chosen to do three runs
and report a confidence interval and
then they have really big wide
overlapping error bars and they say this
to me well
but my asian environment is huge and
doing more runs requires way too much
compute
and that seems like a reasonable defense
but then you should translate that into
what they're really saying they're
really telling you i want to run an
experiment that i don't have enough
reese's for to do well
and so can you just pretend with me that
this result means what i claim it does
because i'm talking about the situation
where they have
overlapping error bars
and they're saying my algorithm is
better than the other one
so they want us to pretend with them
that they have evidence
but there's a clear solution here
which is just ask empirical questions
for which you have
data for and time for like you know a
deadline is not an excuse to run a bad
experiment and if you don't have the
compute for something then ask a
different empirical question
i work at two places i work at deepmind
and the university alberta at deepmind i
have access to like the world's biggest
computer at the university of alberta
with my students i do not we have much
less computational resources i ask
different empirical questions based on
the resources that are available to me
i often like to
to give this relation to you know you're
you're wanting to put a theorem in your
paper but you don't have enough theory
background so you just
don't cover all the cases in your proof
because well i don't have access to a
good theory person like chad that's
that's not legitimate people say okay
then get rid of it
and the third message which you know
depending on time we can we can go
deeper or not is it's about hyper
parameters this is a really really
important thing it's also probably the
most difficult to deal with
which is our algorithms are not that as
not as general as we like
um and that means the performance is
really sensitive to hyperparameters
and so let's just be clear about what
these things are so an agent i call is
something that's an algorithm with the
full specification of this
hyperparameters there's no tunable knobs
left you set everything it's just your
executable
it can perform well in one environment
and completely fail to learn in another
environment this is common you can just
grab an agent that does one well in one
problem and then just directly deploy it
to
a different problem and you'll see this
for yourself and so
how do we think about these things how
do we deal with them
the first thing to do is just consider
what you're trying to do with your
experiment and dealing with hyper ground
there's many different goals you could
have you know the first goal is just i
want to understand how the performance
of my algorithm changes
as i change these key hyper parameters
that's a that's an empirical goal and i
think it's actually a really good goal
to have
your second goal might be you have an
application and you want to deploy your
agent you want to send it off
to control a water treatment plant and
you can't
tune your hypers like we do in
simulators on a water treatment plant
that's literally just not available we
can't do multiple independent runs on
the plant
and data is very expensive
and then the third goal which i think is
actually the most common goal is you
want to prove that your algorithm is the
best it's the state of the art so first
of all i think this is just almost
impossible to do it's certainly
nearly impossible to do well
you could have a better goal that's
still very difficult which is show a
setting where an agent can do better
than others
but as you can see we're kind of
making concessions here to a point where
it's it's not really clear what we're
trying to say
um and we have to keep in mind we want
to keep our results fair and
reproducible
and we want to ensure that the baselines
that we're making this comparative claim
against are reasonably tuned and like i
said in my case study
sam took quite a while to do this
because it was very hard it's compute
expensive
it's a lot of reading tea leaves and
trying to figure out
what things were done where it's just a
lot of burden
and so understanding hyperparameter
sensitivity so that was goal one that i
was talking about here the one where we
just want to better understand our
algorithm not just what its peak
performance is or what the learning
curve looks like
we want to we want to look deeper into
our algorithm we want to understand
how robust in general it is
and so this is a pretty simple recipe
that
that i often follow when trying to do
this which is
you select one key hyper parameter you
understand let's say it's the step size
parameter alpha
then you decide in a range of values to
test so here i've just done powers of
two for alpha a big wide range
and then you have to test your algorithm
for each alpha that's set many many many
times and then aggregate performance so
as you can see this requires a huge
amount of compute
we're not going to get away with k being
1 here
and so this is this is pretty expensive
to do but it is very very useful
provides insight for our algorithm
and you know if we care about deployment
if we care about making our algorithms
parameter free hopefully and not
sensitive to these hypers then these are
the kind of experiments we actually have
to run and confirm that
and so here's a parameter sensitivity
plot so performance is is
on the y-axis so high is good this is
decreasing on acrobat
and so what we want to see here is
we want to see
you know the x-axis is the different
values of the step size we could have
taken so every plot on this line is an
aggregate of the performance of dq on an
acrobat for a different value of the
step cells and this is the kind of thing
we usually want to see a nice bowl here
which means that you know there's
there's a place where there's good
performance possible when we tune alpha
and it's not a sharp peak which means
there's a chance that we can find can
find that good performance because if
it's really peaky like this
that means that it's going to be really
hard to find that sweet spot because
just small changes in the step size
mean that the performance drops
dramatically and so that's going to be a
hard algorithm to deploy
and if it's like this this is
problematic because it just means that
we didn't pick that range of initial
step sizes correctly
and it's likely the performance is even
better
and so again you know if we're doing
these empirical studies in our papers or
even just in you know working for a
company
we can't just look at the mean learning
curves because maybe we're in this
situation where all the step sizes you
tried were not actually the best ones
and there could be even better
performance and we're just
under-representing performance
and so i've kind of put here like you
know
these both correspond to this is a good
situation to be in the middle one where
we have a chance to find a good hyper
primer setting
um and this one the one on the left here
with the with the sharp peak is a bad
situation but it also means maybe we did
a bad hyperparameter study maybe we
needed more
values of alpha in this small range
and then this one of course the one on
on the right with the straight line
going up
is is not a great scenario because
you know we just totally missed the best
performance and now now we're in a
situation where we don't know what's
going on
so this is the kind of insights you can
get from a hyper grammar study like i
said it's very costly to do but it gives
us great insights
but it's important to pause here and say
that sweeping is not an algorithmic
answer
right it's it's an analysis tool to help
us understand our algorithms
but it's almost never feasible in
deployment scenarios especially when
those deployment scenarios are in the
real world
like robots or
or industrial control or anything like
that it's really only feasible in
simulators um and even in simulators you
know just doing a grid search is not the
best option you should probably be
looking to basing methods and other
black box optimization schemes if you
really want to optimize your hyper
parameters
so it's really really best to think of
sweeping as a tool for insight
okay
and of course all of this is related to
um
you know the bass lines
that we're really ultimately going to
want to compare against right so this
idea of untuned bass line which means
you could be misrepresenting the
performance of other methods and this is
just a dangerous situation
so i've kind of come up with like a
little example here
so the common practice is you test your
agent on a new environment let's just
call it gamex
that you invented okay so you came up
with this game you're like this can be a
cool game to test
uh agents on
so
you invent the game and you also come up
with a new algorithm cool
now you want to compare your agent
to dqn on game x so you just go
online and you get nature dqn's hyper
parameter settings and the code and the
network architecture that was used in
atari and you applied
to game x okay and then you see that
your algorithm is better
um so maybe your algorithm is
is the blue one here and the black line
here is is dqm
you're like wow my algorithm is so much
better on game x my algorithm is the
right thing to do for game x
well there's a problem here which is the
dqm is tuned for a chart like there's
all kinds of design choices that were
made for a target
and you'd likely do much much better in
game x if you just retuned the hyper
parameters
for for dqm
because your algorithm is highly trained
for dmx you may not think that's true
but think of the way that algorithms get
developed you have an algorithmic idea
and you develop gamex to test it on and
for a long time it probably didn't work
great and you spent
lots of time tuning and twiddling with
your new algorithm
you are a world expert in your algorithm
and you might have spent literally three
months tuning it so it is really really
fit the game x
whereas we put none of the same effort
into dqm
and so you know the common reactions to
this are well dqm works on everything
nobody does that it's too much compute
to do that
again it's not a good idea and so here
this was just an experiment where this
was dqm
and uh
and this and blue was another algorithm
and then when
we retuned dqm for that problem the
performance got much better and so now
the claims about blue being better than
than dqm are don't hold water at all
and so my advice here is
either invest the significant resources
to re-tune dqn in this case or use an
environment that dqm was used on for
your comparisons because then at least
you know someone else tuned it for you
so
i'm going to leave lots of time for
questions what what is our stopping time
today if someone could tell me
you still have about five minutes if
you'd like to lecture um or we can stop
for questions it's up to you
i probably have a little bit more
talking so this this is worked out
perfect great thank you
so
this talk is just the tip of the iceberg
this is something that i've been
thinking about and writing about for a
really really long time
um
but but i want you to think of some of
these these general principles which is
there's no general recipe to follow here
i'm just trying to get you to think
about think about your experiments and
think about for every experiment you
want to run depending on the comparisons
you want to do or the environments you
want to use or the agents you want to
use you might have to make different
choices and you need to be flexible and
knowledgeable
you need to be a skeptic you need to not
trust yourself i'm sure
everyone in this room when someone shows
them results they'll be skeptical those
results you need to do that to yourself
because your goal in empirical work
is to learn about the thing you're
studying and also to break it because
that helps us understand them
this is this is a huge opportunity for
everyone in this room because good
empiricists are super super rare
and we know that the job market is
competitive you know some people want to
go
become a postdoc or a prof somewhere or
work at a fancy tech company or start
their own company
you know the world's competitive place
even though there's lots of
opportunities there's also high
competition
and being a good empiricist is a huge
competitive advantage because they're so
rare
and it certainly matters in applications
like running bad experiments and then
deploying something that's
you know broken or not the best solution
that's going to cost you money that's
going to cost you the
reputation of your company like it
matters maybe even more so than in our
scientific papers
inflated expectations and unscientific
claims literally lead to ai winters so
we want to be careful of the
community and ecosystem we're building
in our ai community to avoid this kind
of thing
but there's lots of hope you know
there's many good papers i've shared
some of them already
leaders in the field like joel pino one
of our seafarer chairs you know it's
been a leading light in this trying to
to get people to care about these things
and the conferences are introducing
checklists and
you know
program chairs are starting to crack
down on bad empirical practices so
the trend looks like it might be
reversing which is really nice
um
and my contribution this you know beyond
this lecture today is that i've been
working on what i call a cookbook for
better experiments in reinforcement
learning
and so you could think of this as just
like a really long
it's not that long
a really extensive uh
treatment of how to run good experiments
reinforced learning learn literally
starting from
you know
how do we just look at one agent to all
these other different things like you
know select baselines dealing with
episode cutoffs hypothesis testing
benchmark versus challenge problems
averaging over sets of mdps worrying
about multiple hypotheses all these
things best practices common pitfalls
and tons and tons and tons of examples
and so
um the draft of this will be going on my
website today so you guys can go and
check it out
um and i think it it'll be uh
it'll be a very useful resource for
people who are starting off in our owl
and want to run good experiments that
mean something
so just to return to my key messages you
need more seeds than you think
take the statistical point of view think
about the distributions think about how
to characterize the data and what
assumptions you're making
care about hyper parameters
hyperparameter sensitivity is a nice
window in your algorithm but it's not an
algorithmic answer
watch out front turn baselines they're
very very very common
and you know avoid this this fallacy of
appealing to authority right
someone famous in the literature does
bad experiments so therefore i can do it
too and that's that's not true
so thanks for listening and i guess we
can go into questions and i'll just go
back to my key messages slide
thank you very much for the talk um
yes thank you for bringing in the
important messages for really
establishing uh transparency algorithms
or
reinforcement learning and we have a
couple of questions um
during a chat
we'll
start with andrea's question
um in a research word that seems to
value the content called
quantity applications how do we support
the researchers to get more quality and
evaluations faster
there don't seem to be many standards
for evaluation what kind of solutions do
you think would work at the best would
the answer be more evaluation frameworks
code bases or
more theoretical standards
so yeah so how do we how do we make this
more common is standardization way i
don't typically think that
standardization
and code bases are are the way to solve
these problems you know in my master's
eons ago i worked on rl glue which was a
standard benchmarking software for
for reinforcement learning and you know
10 of the most
um well-known rl labs in the world used
it but that still wasn't enough because
researchers tend to always want to do
things just their own way and so they
they typically don't standardize but
maybe worse is that standardization
turns to gatekeeping and it slows down
progress and so the easiest way to see
this is you look at the standard
benchmarks in our community like atari
if you you have a new algorithmic idea
and you show you know with even theory
and small experiments or experiments in
different domains if you don't have
entirely then you get rejected that's
gatekeeping because
you know dq and other methods were tuned
for atari and it's not necessarily
interesting or relevant to tune a brand
new method for atari because that's not
necessarily the deployment scenario you
care about
and so
you know like i said there is no recipe
there is no standard standardization
it's just getting people to care about
whether their experiments are meaningful
and what they're trying to get across
um to follow up on the first question
samuel um asks uh to expand on andrea's
comments and some students reviewers
expect experiments that demonstrate so
this state of the art now run on many
different environments including at
least an impressive one um
one that is expensive to run for example
carla or madruko it makes smaller labs
at the real disadvantage uh if they
don't have the computer resources to run
this uh do you see uh mentalities in
enrollment
um
sorry yeah
this is this is a real performance right
now and it's it's more of the the
gatekeeping that i'm talking about so
first of all let's just be clear
benchmarking is is like well known to
stifle creativity and progress in fields
and all kinds of different fields of
computer science have gone through it so
the search community went through it in
the 90s where everything was focused on
benchmarks people spent ages tuning on
mnist well well beyond when it was
useful
um
even in just general machine learning
you know the uci data sets they were
used to to rank new methods and then
people like rob hulte from alberta went
behind the show all these problems that
you're using are actually meaningless
and so let's think about what it means
to demand good performance on let's say
atari and joku
these are literally arbitrary domains
okay they have certain properties that
are interesting like you know you have
to deal with pixel inputs to do well in
atari
but atari performed a really important
role when was introduced which was we
didn't have hours on the time that could
work okay so it's what i call an
aspirational domain it really drove
research programs
but now it's become a benchmark but a
benchmark is something that we should be
able to use to do good scientific
studies and atari is so big
that doing careful studies like i tried
to outline here many many runs looking
at parameter sensitivity that's
literally impossible for most
researchers to do outside of the big
labs and so we're only going to get
suggested insights from experiment like
entirely and my standard for these kind
of things is always
you should introduce a new algorithm a
new insight you should have one
experiment that shows that that new
algorithm is useful in some situation we
care about and that can be a small
experiment that could be
you know
like a grid role almost and then you
should run your algorithm on some small
benchmarks that you can you can have
statistical certainty about the
conclusions just to show that it doesn't
do anything stupid
now this is not what reviewers ask for
but we can't use that as the standard
because reviewers by large right now the
pool is very weak
and the reviewing decisions are quite
arbitrary and we just need to fight and
do a better job as an area chair when i
have reviewers that are asking for those
things i challenge them in the
discussion
to tell me what they're asking for and
usually i make progress on them and make
them think differently and basically
that's the game we have to just keep
doing the right thing
i think um
like one brief follow up on those
questions it seems like as researchers
we're always incurred to show what works
um
like if we propose something we should
also pretend to encourage um just as a
part of the review process to show the
further cases
um that's right
that's hugely important right because
what are we after we're after insights
and we're after understanding and
knowledge and so those failure cases are
are part of it right and
and so this fascination with with state
of the art
is is just an arbitrary fascination and
like i said it's not super relevant to
deployment but those failure cases are
really relevant to deployment because
they might say maybe you shouldn't
deploy this item because it failed so
badly
yeah okay
thanks um so we have another question
from drow uh do you think reviewers
should start rejecting papers that use
programs and simply show average and
standard general division of the results
or more generally reject papers that
don't prove statistical significance of
their results
yeah so i'll i'll just be
straightforward and honest if someone
if someone has overlapping error bars
someone uses
three runs and uh a standard normal
consumable without any explanation of
why that's appropriate
i
i move to reject that paper and what of
course i give the authors the chance you
know explain to me why you think this is
appropriate
show me the empirical evidence why these
assumptions are valid or do more runs i
always get the opportunity to do that
but
but if they if they don't budge if they
say the thing like that's too much
compute or that's not what other papers
do then i indeed reject those papers
um
one more question from adria
publications tend to have limits on the
number of pictures and evaluation
sometimes tends to be left to the end
and not explained well how do we publish
complicated evaluation setups analysis
results in a detailed complete way
while keeping in mind the limitations
absolutely this is a great question
right and so
before i answer it i'll flip to say well
imagine you were comparing you know
five large deep learning systems on
mojoku
and we have a short eight pages and
we're also introducing a new algorithm
and motivating it and talking about
related work well for that much more
complicated experiment you definitely
didn't have time to explain all the
setup and all the nuances and how you
tune the bass lines and all those things
so in fact this is a good argument for
why we should think carefully about
running such big experiments it's more
tractable to do that with something like
carpool and mountain carbon we
understand the results and the baselines
might be much simpler but yeah we
you know
detailed description of experiments has
to be a first-class citizen in our
papers we can save space by saying we
did an
extensive hyper-primer tuning and the
process is described in detail in the
appendix and then actually put it in the
appendix
um
but yeah we're gonna have to make use of
the appendix but we also have to make
sure that the paper
clearly demonstrates the reader that
we're following good empirical practice
thanks
um
one question from raja uh using us to
impress and confuse readers um is so
spot on i like to
ask why do you think empirical only
wearing protocol heavy papers or cell
phone album if they don't have an
adequate theoretical section
accompanying it or perhaps that's the
impression i have
sorry where was this question i just
want to read myself
it's at the top of the q and a
i figured
you were uh going it yeah in order of
upvotes so at the top right yeah if you
sort it
um and then you can see yeah uh what was
the question asker's name again
okay maybe i'm not finding can maybe you
just restate the question again i'm
sorry
um using math to impress and confuse
readers are so spot on i would like to
ask
i would like to ask why do you think
empirical only or empirical heavy papers
are so frowned upon if they don't have
an adequate theoretical section
accompanying it
or perhaps that's the impression it has
yeah so
um i i agree i don't think papers need
to have uh
theoretical sections i think you know
there's huge value in empirical studies
that just compare existing methods in
interesting ways and give these kind of
deeper insights that i talked about like
we don't know
the hyper parameter sensitivity of many
algorithms
we don't have good
you know studies like
across them so the revisiting rainbow
paper was really nice because they tried
to do this but we need more papers like
that that paper didn't have any theory
um
i
i think it was true five years ago that
papers without theory were frowned upon
but now actually i think even theory is
getting thrown upon i have experience
with
papers where we introduced a new
algorithm we have some interesting
theory about it and extensive
experiments and all the reviewers cared
about with state-of-the-art and
benchmarks they didn't even mention the
theory as a contribution so i think
actually um the pendulum has swung quite
a bit towards just benchmark performance
and they don't even care about
not everyone of course but some
reviewers don't even care about that
okay
um i think we have next question from
draw have you read uh debris first
learning at the edge of the statistical
principle
um
how much do you think their proposed
message and library
reliable
help
yeah um so i have read that paper um
it's by a good friend of mine mark
belmair
he cares about these issues a lot i
think
i think what they propose is is a really
good good way to analyze your data i
think
that's not the silver bullet as in you
know chopping off the the top
part of the performance distribution in
the bottom part of the performance
distribution does solve some problems
but it doesn't solve all your problems
and we talk about in the cookbook about
you know when you might want to use that
and when you might want to use other
statistical tools
thanks um
our next question is from andrea and you
mentioned standardization slows down
progress however if you don't have a
standardization i'll come and compare
evaluations from different papers that
follow very different evaluation designs
so i
i didn't mean to say that
standardization slows down progress i
might have misspoke what i meant is that
researchers don't like standardization
and they resist it because they always
want to do things exactly their own way
i think um
arbitrary gatekeeping with benchmarks
slows down progress and that's not
standardization that's just
they're like
i can i can share with you guys uh a
really old paper from 1995 from the
the journal of heuristics talking about
the they literally call it like the
evils of benchmarking and that's what
i'm talking about that's the kind of
thing that slows down progress
standardization can mean many things it
could mean standard code it could mean
standard problems but it could also just
mean
asking very clear empirical questions
and in a very standard way using proper
statistical tools
providing support for those empirical
claims that's a form of standardization
that we definitely need do we need
standardization in terms of software
i'm not sure
um
your next question is from lutz have you
faced foot back from your peers when
roughly advocating for better empirical
experiments the system often and
synthesizes quantity over
quantity over
quality
um
i maybe i just have great peers and
friends i don't i don't get much
pushback in this i get a lot of um
agreement and
and wondering how we could solve the
problem you know the more common
reaction is
yes this is very important yes you're
right but it's not clear we can do
anything about it um
in terms of quality over quantity yeah i
mean
the
the metrics that people drive on in
different places are different you know
at my university it's not my
my performance is not measured by my
publication output but it's measured by
the contributions of my research and i
think good schools evaluate profs that
way good companies evaluate scientists
and engineers that way
and so
basically you have to do the right thing
and uh and if you're at a place where
they're encouraging bad behavior you
have to wonder
what that means
thanks
do we have time for two more questions
um first one is from reggie i love
really news reproducibility checklist
especially where it mentions the seats
and their values but i still don't see
that being rightly being adopted
papers and accompanying code um
sorry it jumps a little bit
papers and company codes don't include
the seat values even today
at top conferences even although the
justification given is that this are
just 10 random values but i
want to know what values were those
what are your thoughts on why
reproducibility checklist or similar
methodologies haven't touched on even
through
uh so
2018 was so long ago
yeah i mean i think the the checklist
help i think the checklist helped mainly
for the reason that they forced people
to pause and think about these really
important questions um
[Music]
you know people have different views on
this like you know
um dave silver
isn't us
likes to say that you know one of the
important aspects of reproducibility is
that it forces someone to go behind
someone else and see if they can
recreate the main idea without detailed
instructions and i think that's true i
think there's a huge value in people
doing that
taking a clear description from a paper
and trying to recreate
the main essence of the result and i
think there's also just an efficiency
argument for code releases and
reproducibility
where
you know instead of slowing everyone
down figuring how to make something work
and emailing the authors 10 times we can
just know right away by hitting run on
something and there's of course clear
value in that why people don't do it i
guess the answer is because it's not
enforced you know the reviewers
and
and other people involved in reviewing
are not enforcing enforcing that
standard at nurips this year
we just rejected all papers that didn't
include their checklist
and so there was there was no discussion
about it they were just rejected and so
i think
you know if we want to take these things
seriously then we have to
have consequences
um thanks and we have one last question
uh hyper parameters which are always
expensive and it's kind of uh obvious
that each model should converge before
making any conclusion with respect to
the hyper parameters of that run however
they need
many apples sometimes it is reasonable
to do low rep apple comparisons with a
high number of samples or it will always
be biased and it's better to stick to
the fully trained models
yeah so this is an interesting question
um
i know you're coming from probably like
a supervised learning background but i
think about this as an rl person
which is you know your the length of
your experiment should be related to
what you want to learn for instance you
could run an experiment for
you know a short period of time because
you're interested in how quickly the
system can learn you might run your
experiment for a really long time
because you want to see
does it remain stable for a very long
period of time so the runs for each
hyperparameter don't necessarily need to
be long it depends on the question
you're asking
but then the other answer is actually
you can get away with surprisingly fewer
runs for each hyperparameter than you
may think as long as you follow a
two-stage procedure which is
you sweep your hyper-parameters and you
do a few runs for each one of them and
then you pick
um like the top ten percent of those
performing hyper parameters and then you
do a lot of runs with them
and that way you have much more
certainty that you're actually going to
do a good job of representing the
performance
of the algorithm it'll never be perfect
you might have missed the best hyper
parameter you might have been unlucky
but this is something we talk about in
the cookbook and this is why i said you
know sweeping hyper parameters to get
good performance and then to compare
algorithms is very very difficult to do
well and it's fraught with difficulty
but we do have opinions about it in the
cookbook if you want to check it out
hi adam um i've accidentally checked off
samuel's question twice so i'm going to
direct message it to you and i'll read
it out to the audience as well
um so what do you think about including
wall clock comparisons in addition to
number of steps and episodes a lot of
new work proposes a new module to
popular existing algorithm using the
vanilla algorithm as the baseline
it's a little unfair to to never mention
wall clock time since often the module
makes the agent use more compute per
time step
yeah so i'm generally an advocate for
multiple views on the performance of an
algorithm one of those important views
is how long it takes to run it's not
just the wall clock time you know if you
take a vanilla algorithm and then add
stuff on top of it you're already in a
dangerous spot right because you're just
introducing a new hyper parameter
possibly that you can tune and then you
can tune that and always make
performance better that's just that's
just an easy thing to do
um so yeah wall clock time is really
important of course it's not
easy or obvious how to do that because
you know in reinforcement learning
popular big architectures use multiple
parallel actors and so how do you
measure the runtime of that thing
those might actually run really really
quickly but then they use way more
compute so i think we ultimately care
about how much computation is being used
because that will be relevant
in a lot of deployment scenarios where
you either have limited compute or one
computer
um but yeah absolutely very
very spot on
okay um i guess we're running out of
time and thank you again adam for
bringing
those important messages for good rl
practices thanks
[Music]
you